while he the most striking being like
Rodman speech was that this is the first
conference at the joys of had since they
won a majority and yet George Osborne
devoted a large chunk of it to the need
to win over labour voters he talked
about winning over those working people
who still voted in their millions for
labor at the last election I think we
saw some ideas of how he's going to do
that and I thought the the new
announcement speech was this devolution
revolution which has allows local
councils in England to keep all of
business rates what I ain't swipes
significant about that is that the
Treasury traditionally has been the
great centralizing Department and you've
now got a chancellor who is championing
devolution and I think it's because he
sees it as a way to push through
center-right ideas he hopes that these
local councils will cut business rates
in an attempt to generate more revenue
and that will shift the political debate
in Britain I thought George Osborne
speech was a very sober speech about the
challenges that the Conservatives still
faced in terms of winning back labour
voters for instance he still hadn't
backed the Conservatives in May I
thought it was quite a big vision speech
as well it obviously included his
national infrastructure commission which
was trailed overnight that has lauded
onus as its not New crossbench peer
chair and it included a big reform which
is the end of local government grant and
councils being able to keep their rates
and the abolition of the uniform
business rates their councils can set
their business rates as well
well I think that George Osborne's
problem at the moment is that he is the
front-runner so I actually thought this
was quite a tone down speech in terms of
leadership there was there was no great
long credo section he didn't try and do
that march on his own personal backstory
or anything like that but instead I
think they saw him doing some chunky big
things I think that is what his [ __ ]
Natori party ultimately will be but he
is the guy he's got the big vision and
he takes the big decision well I think
this has been a good speech for his
leadership chances in that it went down
well in the hall it was a sort of sober
assessment of where the Conservatives
need to go next but the local business
rate reform is huge and it's usually
detail and complex and actually it won't
be so much the speech that impacts as
leadership chances as whether those
reforms what will work and won't lead to
a rebellion into local government or
whether taurino her government like she
really liked being given this freedom
well I thought it was it was slightly
less tub-thumping perhaps and some of
them I it didn't have but they're kind
of the crown pleasing showstopper of the
inheritance tax cut but I also put it
was quite a serious featuring this is
ultimately you know a speech about local
government finance it is not something
that generally gets people's hearts
racing but I thought it was a warm out
that he is a going who does big things
all that was a message he wanted to get
across what husband's refrain rules we
are the builders we're the party who are
going to do things were going to make
big decisions such as on infrastructure
and also to free up local government to
make its own decisions to compete and
actually to give it the responsibility
for growth in its area rather than
making central government responsible
now obviously this is also convenient
because there's a spending review coming
up where local government grant was
going to be cut hugely anyway so it's
one way of developing some of the pain
to local government as well but
obviously Osborne didn't acknowledge
that he did talk a little bit about
labor in his speech about Labor refusing
to make decisions to be on the side of
the the fee rather than the many but
actually most of you speak really was
about his legacy projects about the
northern powerhouse about what he wants
to do to make the case for him being
Prime Minister having been a successful
Chancellor
well the holic conservative conference
is quite old it's huge and a lot of the
atmosphere just gets sucked away by its
size and the speeches that I've heard
I've heard all of the speeches at this
conference so far none of them have
really taken the roof off partly because
the reef is so far away from the
delegates but it was well received I saw
lots of knots of councillors afterwards
standing around trying to work out what
this means for their local area and I
think that there'll be a lot of debate
about whether this works for rural areas
for poorer areas but it was certainly a
speech that really engaged people's
interest and everyone turned up to see
him not just because he's a chance liver
because he's the man of the moment in
terms of the leadership contest